[Música]
hace tan solo una semana que Igor Este
joven ruso llegó a Turquía la prisa por
adaptarse a este nuevo país y aprender
un nuevo idioma a premian y sus nuevos
compañeros de clase no son turistas son
exiliados rusos que huyeron del
reclutamiento forzoso que Rusia anunció
el pasado 21 de Septiembre
tengo 8 amigos que recibieron el llamado
afilas pero como yo se fueron Así que no
es un problema muy grande pero tengo
otros amigos que fueron llamados y
fueron al centro de reclutamiento allí
le esforzaron a firmar los documentos
ahora no pueden salir de Rusia
según las estimaciones cerca de un
millón de rusos ha abandonado Rusia
desde el inicio de la guerra sobre todo
hacia kazajistán Georgia Armenia y
Turquía y este otoño con el llamado
afilas organizaciones de Derechos
Humanos estiman que las cifras
incluso gente que antes apoyaba lo que
la propaganda Estatal le decía ahora ya
no quiere apoyar lo que ocurre con sus
acciones ni sus propias vidas nadie
quiere seriamente ir allí y luchar las
posibilidades de sobrevivir y volver
vivo o sin traumas o sin heridas graves
son muy bajas
y otros jóvenes han dejado todo atrás en
Rusia este joven era químico alimenticio
y ahora en Turquía comenzará a trabajar
en una cafetería en la ciudad del
bósforo caso parecido al deseosa que
abandonó su país y su carrera en una
empresa tecnológica y aún no tiene una
oportunidad laboral en el lugar donde
decidió emigrar
no planeo de ninguna manera volver a
Rusia en un futuro cercano hasta que
haya un cambio Así que estando fuera no
me importa ya demasiado se recibo el
llamado a filas de hecho si pasa puede
que me ayude a conseguir una visa para
quedarme seguro en otro sitio este
asegura que la guerra le rompió todos
sus planes de trabajo de vida y de
futuro que ahora ya no sabe qué hacer ni
qué pasará pero si estás seguro de algo
abandonar Rusia no ir a la guerra fue la
decisión acertada